everybody and welcome back to the polka
text campaign let's get right into it
today I want to play a coaster Canyon Oh
let me click on that today I want to
play coaster Canyon which is a barren
desert canyon with ample land available
for construction and it provides a
perfect spot for a new tourist
attraction
a giant cliffside hypercoaster is the
first step for the soon-to-be roller
coaster paradise and the objectives are
to get six coasters in the park with an
excitement rating of 50 or above which
in terms of excitement rating that's not
too difficult actually and we also need
to get 550 guests in the park so I I
kind of feel like I might reach that
guest goal before I meet the coaster
goal but we'll see what happens and then
we also have the optional go of having
700 guests in the park which like I said
I might actually reach that optional
goal but I'm probably not going to reach
the the optional goal of reaching all of
the other objectives before the end of
August year two because you know that's
just me
anyway let's get into the scenario this
is one of the scenarios that I made so I
kind of know this this map like the back
of my hand but I didn't really play this
scenario myself so I'm not actually that
experienced when it comes to it now
there's two rides we've got the giant
hyper coaster cascade and a simple
orbiter here and we're gonna have to
start with checking up some of the
prices on these things I think you could
easily make this 550 maybe even six but
I'm not entirely sure I'm gonna start
off with this first and cascade can
easily be 12 I'm quite sure that people
are going to be willing to pay that
actually I have to say that the stats on
this are a bit disappointing for such a
huge coaster I guess it just doesn't
have any noteworthy forces but yeah the
most interesting thing about this map is
just this giant cliffside which can
provide a lot of cool interaction with
rollercoasters which this is kind of an
example of but you can probably Wigga in
some different coasters in there as well
and then we have some land on the other
side of this river but most of the land
in the scenario is this giant flat space
in the middle so you do get a lot of
space here now I have to say I want to
build a sort of Wild West steampunk
of park but before I start building I
need to give a shout out to asteroids
Ron who makes amazing poetic videos and
he posts a lot of really cool content on
the poetic discord but also on Facebook
and reddit and he came up with that the
the steampunk Wild West the theme for
this map before me
I wish I could take credit for that but
um I guess we we saw the like on this
map anyway his stuff is really great and
it's always been an inspiration to me
honestly so I just wanted to shout him
out on this episode but with that said
let's get into building stuff so the
first thing that I wanted to build here
is a food courts because well the park
doesn't really have any food options so
far and the Depot is very conveniently
right next to the park entrance so I
don't need to make any other external
depots I can just use this place to
supply these stores I might actually
have to open another food court
somewhere else in the park just because
this park is quite large but for now I'm
sticking to this one now this building
was generally inspired by and I want to
say inspired by very carefully because
it doesn't look like it at all
but it was generally inspired by the
armor Steiner house which is an octagon
house that is absolutely one of my
favorite buildings in the world probably
it's one of the most steampunk looking
buildings ever I think it looks more
steampunk than a million cogs and pipes
and gears combined it's this really old
Victorian house in an octagon shape that
is basically just one large dome looking
kind of like a traditional Roman domed
temple and it just has all of these
really amazing Victorian details and is
really slightly spooky looking steampunk
aesthetic to it although that's
something that's more in hindsight
because steampunk as a genre really just
developed around this kind of
architecture but yeah it's an absolutely
amazing building unfortunately it's bit
difficult to make octagon shaped shaped
buildings in park attacked and also it's
quite difficult to make a deist
looking dome so I decided to go with
completely different shapes but the
overall idea of a completely round
almost symmetrical but not quite looking
building and even some of the colors are
based on the armor Steiner house so
that's for the little food court there
just found it a bit interesting to also
share some of my interests here and with
that said I want to move into the new
coaster because I'm gonna need to open
five more coasters if I want to finish
the scenario so basically I was building
that building just to let more time pass
and research more coasters in hopes of
getting a good coaster type and that
paid off in the end because I got the
Eurofighter or as it's called in-game
the vertical drop coaster which is
probably one of my favorite coaster
types just because it's so versatile so
I was really happy to get that and I
thought it might be interesting to have
a vertical lift he'll run up to the
cliffside and then do a very small
turnaround above that and after a one
break run just crash into the valley and
do a couple of big elements there so
that's basically what I'm doing here and
I'm again using that little trick of
trying to make a slightly more steep
inversion then you could normally do
without the autocomplete function so
there's a little bit of hard lining so
that dive loop which I think always
looks quite neat but it is always a bit
of a trial and error process to try and
get it right and to try and get the auto
complete to actually connect the pieces
but when you get it I think it's really
just satisfying how smooth it becomes
after that it just does a large 0 0 and
a sidewinder inside the cave and after
that it comes out and I was messing for
a while with how I wanted the second
part of the write to go because I wasn't
really sure I eventually ended up going
for a mid-course break run here for
capacities sake as well because this is
a Eurofighter in the end and these
trains are really small so I'm gonna
need as many break runs as I can fit
into this coaster and yeah after that's
a small one
sort of dive elements very similar to
lost gravity in wallaby which you get a
lot of great hang time in which I think
is fairly typical for a girl our coaster
so I thought that would probably fit
into the coasters well after which we
have a large corkscrew and then a helix
elements which I'm still trying to mess
with here in the end I think this
coaster is a bit ridiculous and a little
bit over-the-top
you would probably not see a coaster
like this in real life but I tried to
base it as much as I could on the way
that girl our coasters tend to be built
in real life so it features very many of
the similar kind of elements as they do
in real life and just generally I think
the layouts would be almost believable
if it weren't for the fact that it's
crashing down from a cliff and it has a
sidewinder inside a cave which is a bit
over the top now for this station I'm
trying to build some Western steampunk
ish buildings but it's not going to be
too over-the-top steampunk I'm not going
to have pipes and things like that go
everywhere
partly because I just don't have pipes
in the scenery back in this scenario so
I can't rely on all of those steam
details that packet X has to carry the
steampunk theme so I'm really just
basing this on textures and the shapes
and the overall look of buildings and
for that I figured those those steam
roofs which are the green ones that you
can see here would work very well as the
main cover of the station and then to
give it some slightly more interesting
shapes and not make the station
essentially a box I'm adding a larger
overhanging roof right in front of that
and that is basically the the basic
shape of this station it's very simple
but it also kind of divides it up into
two compartments because a lot of this
coaster is based around having it and as
good capacity as possible and it's for
that reason that I have a separate
unloading station and a loading station
which I am so glad that this works in
park tanks because it's something that
you know you kind of want to have
realistically because a lot of real-life
coasters do this but it also helps out a
great deal
with capacity so at the end of the day
you can see that this thing has many
cars going through it and pretty much a
car entering and leaving this station at
all times in total I'm running five cars
on this and they never have to wait on a
block break except for the last one they
have to wait for it a little bit so I'm
super happy with them actually this is
probably one of my most yeah efficient
coasters in terms of capacity it might
not have the best capacity but it will
be difficult to draw much more capacity
out of a large Eurofighter like this so
I'm really happy with that
and with the facts how you can just see
trains go up the lift or time and time
again which is really cool and then I'm
adding some buildings here just to hide
this staff room basically because as
soon as I plopped down employees I saw
that they were becoming very tired very
quickly because there was a lot to do
for some reason this Park started off
with all of the lamps broken so I had to
get mechanics to go around and fix all
of that stuff and then I quickly had to
place down a staff room for them to rest
after they did all of that work so I'm
just building these western-style
buildings here just to hide all of that
but I'm adding some slight steampunky
details to it I would say like the the
spire decorations on the blue building
and then the the metal steamed spire on
the other building it's not over-the-top
I think and it's very subtle but it's
not the most typical Western style
building I'm trying to make everything
at least a tiny bit more gritty and
industrial looking then the theme would
typically be and finally I wanted to
place a flat right here just to fill up
this space and I didn't have a choice
but build an enterprise because that's
all that we have at the moment but I
think that also fits the slightly
steampunk theme and it makes for an
interesting interaction also between the
enterprise and the coaster because the
enterprise goes almost vertical and it
comes very close to the coaster when it
does then actually so it's not too often
that you see an interesting kind of
inter
action between a coaster and the flat
ride because flat rides are pretty
static most of the times and don't
really come off their place very much
but I think with an enterprise you can
actually do some really interesting
things I love these things also I could
definitely write these time and time
again until at some point after a few
rides my stomach does get very crumbly
though butts and surprises are honestly
a really cool kind of relaxing ride I
think and probably as in terms of going
upside down
it definitely features quite a bunch of
loops anyway moving on I'm adding two
new coasters on this side I figured it
would make sense to build a dueling
coaster because that adds quite a bit of
coasters to the coaster counts and I was
waiting basically for research this
whole time because I was getting a lot
of coaster types that I wasn't really a
big fan of I actually tried building a
suspended coaster between this but that
never really turned into much good so
decided to bend that idea and after
that's I got the hyper coaster which is
an absolutely beautiful coaster type so
I figured I could go for some kind of
dueling hyper coaster here now I have to
say strictly speaking depending on if
you want to have the loose or strict
definition of a hyper coaster these
coasters aren't hyper coasters because
they're not tall enough but I guess this
would be like a B and M mega coaster if
they were actually using that term
there's one in China that was opened
about a year ago which I totally forgot
the name about it had something to do
with music but anyway that looked really
cool and then had some really funky
elements and kind of different from most
bnm hyper coasters as well it didn't
just focus on straight airtime but it
had a lot of curves and banked hills in
the middle of the layouts as well which
I thought was really interesting and I
figured a layout like that could work
very well especially if I'm trying to
build thrilling hyper coasters which you
know admittedly is something that
doesn't exist and I'm not sure how well
it would work in the real world but I
think here it's a it's a pretty
interesting mix of coasters and I'm
trying to make these Tango as much as I
can and I'm trying to make these things
interact and kind of cross each other's
paths as much as I can because that's
just about the only really exciting
thing you can do with dueling hyper
coasters you can't have interlocking
loops or loops that meet each other like
dragon challenge did with coasters that
do go upside down and the first half was
actually pretty quickly built I didn't
even need to test this first half like
the coasters were pretty much
automatically just perfectly in sync so
I was super happy with that and then my
second idea was to do this kind of
diamond height style where they go apart
in the second half of the layouts and
just do their own little airtime Hills
so that's what I started out with and I
can already say that eventually I didn't
go with this layout option because it
just didn't do all enough because part
of a dueling coaster is just that like
you want the trains to be close to each
other or at least I have certain moments
where they meet up and where they cross
each other's paths so the two tracks
being apart like this I was kind of
defeating the purpose of a dueling
coaster but also I had extreme
difficulties trying to get this second
track to go back to this station without
intercepting the other track and it was
even more difficult to get these to
actually be in sync when I was doing it
like this so eventually I had to bend
this idea I'm also just not a fan of how
it looks in general I really preferred a
kind of very interactive type of layouts
and then there's the fact that I
realistically probably had to make use
of the river valley because at this
point the coasters had lost a lot of
speed so if I want one of the coasters
to remain on the high ground on the
other side of the station it's not gonna
be that fast anymore so it would
probably be better to have it go through
the river valley make sure that I use as
much of that potential energy that you
get from the lift as possible and then
once they return to the station they've
pretty much used up all of their energy
which is the perfect case scenario for a
coaster so yeah that's how I decided to
change the layout
in the end it also made for some
slightly more interacts slightly more
interesting interaction between the two
layouts I think since you've got one of
the coasters just doing a simple airtime
Hill routine and then the other coaster
doing s bends right next to it so you
get some more interesting interaction
there although I also have to say that
probably makes one of the coasters way
less fun than the other one because one
of them has to straight great airtime
Hills in a row and the other one just
does a bunch of S bends in that place
but hey maybe not everybody is like
coaster enthusiasts and maybe some
people really prefer a spends over
airtime Hills I know I wouldn't but at
least I was trying to compensate with
the airtime Hill going over the other
coaster that you do on the coaster that
does these S pen's anyway again I was
getting into a bit of a predicament when
it comes to the break room because it
was quite difficult to get the second
coaster to go over the other one to
enter the break run in a decent-looking
way and one of the weirdest things is
that something that I noticed is that
one of the coasters had lost a lot of
energy during the layouts and the other
one hadn't so basically that the coaster
that goes over the other one in this
final curve here was going faster by the
end of the layout than the other one and
it was only slightly so but because of
that it was losing the race or now it
was winning the race every time no
matter how much I tried to change the
layouts and no matter how much track
lengths I tried to add to it at the end
here it would always win and I found
this really weird or at least it was
understandable I figured it wouldn't
have lost as much energy because it does
these airtime Hills instead of s bends
so yeah there are more parts where the
layout is slower the track is shorter
but slower in general so I think that
makes sense but then the strangest thing
is that when I closed this this park
file and reopen it later for some reason
the coasters were way out of saying
and the course that used to be faster
was suddenly a lot slower well
relatively and they had about the same
speed as they moved into the final brake
run so I don't know what's up with that
I have no idea why for some reason the
coaster would become slower upon closing
the park file and reopening it but
whatever happened I just reopened the
park file here and you can see me
changing all of the colors and then
basically you can see the testing
happening in the background at this
point I had already changed the layouts
so you could see that the curve is
shorter on the top coaster again and
they are now perfectly in sync when they
enter the station no idea why that whole
thing happened though and why I had to
fix it in the end just find it strange
that the speed of the coasters would
change even if it's just slightly upon
reopening the park file but in the end I
think it's kind of a good thing as weird
as it is because it forced me to go back
and change the layout a little bit and
this time I was able to get the coasters
so much in sync that sometimes one of
the closest wins and sometimes the other
one wins and honestly that's something
that I've never been able to reach in
architects whenever I've made dueling
coasters there would always be one train
that always wins even if it's just by a
slight margin but these guys are now
entering the station at pretty much
exactly the same time which is
absolutely awesome and I really don't
know how it happened but I'm actually
kind of glad for it now because it means
that this is a proper dueling coaster as
you can want to have one in real life so
I'm really happy with it this is
probably one of my favorites if not my
favorite courses that I've made in the
game so far so yeah not gonna complain
about it I just found it really strange
how the speed had changed upon reloading
the save file but it just kind of fixed
the coaster in the end now I'm building
the station here which was loosely
inspired by these old Victorian train
stations with the large ironwork roofs
although I had to curve for these very
pointy
curved roofs here because those are just
the curved groups that we have in park
text and just because I'm a spider-man I
decided to build a spire on top of it as
well and this is quite a large and
chunky spire making up a 2x2 grid space
which is really big but in the end the
station is very big in general so I
don't I don't feel like it's really too
big for this station building and it
also means that I can add a whole lot of
details to this thing so that's
basically what I'm doing here there are
clocks at some parts there's a lot of
different wooden posts and decorations
and finally some dormers with windows
all the way at the top and then just
once
one final roof spire above that so it's
a very complicated spire structure but I
think it works quite well and all the
pieces come together pretty coherently
and that is basically the main draw and
maybe even the main weenie for this
whole area of the park and the thing
that will hopefully make people cross
that wooden bridge into these the area
with these coasters to write these
things I should have probably opened the
coasters at this point but I was too
clearly building to remember then I
should probably open these but still as
you can see every time they come into
the station you really can't even tell
which of the trains is winning and which
of the trains is losing which I'm just
so happy about and then when it comes to
the final brake run here and decided to
put a roof over this as well and some
extra supports just to make the station
a bit bigger make it fit a bit better
into the scale of that gie inspire and
then for the cue lines I'm adding these
two identical little buildings to have
some kind of cover over this switch
track section but aside from that the
cue lines are not going to be too
intricately themed or anything and I
think this is again also kind of where
this steampunk feeling of the park comes
in I'm not really adding any gears or
other steam elements to this although I
have to say I did research the scenery
in the meantime
and I did get the gears and all of those
moving steampunk bits which is really
cool but in the end I decided not to use
them and just keep everything more
subtle but I think the giant iron roof
of this station
the intricate spire and the brass
looking roofs over the queue at least
signify some of that steampunk aesthetic
that I was going for plus some of the
some of the lamps and other path
elements and decorations that I'm using
are from the Steamworks sets in Pocket X
but yeah I find it really cool that
architects actually does have seen me
that's specifically geared to steampunk
so maybe I'll go and fully and develop
myself into a steampunk theme in some
scenario in the future but I can't give
any spoilers about that one but yeah
it'll probably happen but for now I'm
sticking mostly to different themes here
and finally I wanted to build some kind
of flat ride somewhere before I went
back into a real time section and just
show you these coasters but it was
really difficult to fit anything into
that other space because there's a lot
of coasters there so in the end I
decided to just put a simple carousel
right next to the entry of this bridge
here and that's basically that's it's
not going to be too flashy I'm once
again just trying to come up with a
slightly different roof structure from
the roofs that I've put on camera cells
so far but this thing is really not too
special I really say it's kind of a
filler addition into the park I did
decide to add some glass on top of the
roof which realistically doesn't really
make sense but this being an isometric
game I thought it would be a nice way to
make layer that somewhere underneath
that roof is actually a carousel so yeah
this is something that really only works
if you're looking at the park from above
but I thought it would be a nice
addition to it and yeah that is
basically it for this whole area I'm
just adding some final small details
around the paths here and adding some
small foliage elements finally also a
catwalk for the break run of the
Eurofighter but that's about it for this
time-lapse
so let's go into a quick real-time
section and see what the park looks like
all right so let's take a look at what
we have here is the food courts and
these two other buildings hiding the
staff room and finally the yet-unnamed
Eurofighter so I'm just gonna give this
a quick POV I think you can call this a
POV even though it's not entirely on
right so yeah we drop down into this
little dip here which I thought would be
a fun way to start the ride kind of a
bit of a teaser and then here's the
brakes that also function as block
brakes that's one extra train on the
circuit into this large drop a very
smooth tight loop and thing here and
into a smooth very gradual in zero-g
roll over the past and then inside
there's a sidewinder which is a bit
strange but it's the best way to turn
around there into another break section
just as the other car comes off the lift
hill so the timing on that is quite
tight actually and then into this
corkscrew finally a helix and once we're
out of that it's into another block
break section and it doesn't even need
to be stopped here oh right it's the
first lock breaks that it stopped at so
yeah this is the whole reason how the
track is actually so efficient you
always have one car waiting on these
block brakes waiting for the next car to
clear the lift hill and as soon as it
does that it won't well go on this and
it pretty much matches the timing of the
rest of the right so I think the thing
that's most important here is that the
lift Hill is long enough to have a
longer duration than any other block on
the entire ride but yeah in the end I
think it works out quite well and it
makes for a pretty efficient coaster oh
and I want to quickly give these things
a POV let me just get on this train so
these things also have no name yet but
here you can probably see how they work
and what they look like we're currently
on the purple one so yeah I think that
works out I'm actually gonna move the
camera a bit so we get a better view of
the airtime Hills but as you can see
they meet up exactly over here with the
way that the S pen's work then they go
underneath the other train and finally I
think this one might win I'm not
entirely sure I'm actually gonna have to
hide scenery here but yeah it's very
hard to tell I really can't tell which
train won on that occasion let's do a
quick view v if the green one here but
yeah I love the interaction that leads
to coasters have with each other I feel
like I kind of accidentally built a
really good layout on these things
unfortunately the guests aren't really
filling it up completely yet but still
I'm pretty sure that these make plenty
of money already so you can see that
every element is slightly different and
here on those curves you've got some
really cool interaction here they go and
cross paths again at the same time
ooh Green is far ahead over here but
here they cross again and I think Green
is gonna win this one looks like green
is ahead yeah on that airtime Hill
especially you can tell but I'm not
entirely sure actually no green lost
that one yeah that was clearly lost by
green anyway you can see here how the
interaction between these dueling
coasters works very well and sometimes
there's a clear winner and sometimes
there really isn't and this is also the
first time that I'm noticing that guests
really seem to have quite an effect on
how course is run unfortunately both of
these trains are pretty empty so you
can't really know it's a very stark
difference but at some point I had one
almost completely full train and an
almost empty train and the full train
won by a mile on that one so I think you
can really tell a difference here let's
see if we can actually have a train that
is more different than these so far
doesn't look that way yeah that looks
like another win for purple actually
even if it's just very slight and this
is also kind now this is also
interesting and kind of realistic
sometimes they slightly mess up the
dispatch time so one train will leave
slightly earlier than the other one I
think we can see at the bottom of the
drop here yeah you can see the first
drop is entirely identical for both
coasters but green is ever so slightly
ahead of purple here so it's really cool
how they have these minor differences
now from looking at the courses go
around a few times I'm very certain that
purple actually wins most of the times
even if it's by a slight margin but I've
seen some right where green is more full
than purple is and in that case green
wins so yeah it's not a perfectly
Dueling coaster but then again that's
extremely difficult to even get close to
but it's about as close as I think you
can realistically get in parsecs like on
that one
I could hardly make out a winner it
seemed like purple is slightly first but
something to keep in mind is that green
enters the break run with more speed
then purple does because purple is
coming from above here and green is
coming up so they're always even now
it's once they're halfway through the
the break run so it's really hard to
tell exactly who wins in that scenario
and we're I guess the finishing line
would be anyway that's it for this quick
overview of what the pipe looks like so
far I'm gonna add two more coasters
because that's what I need I'm almost at
500 people so can't be too worried about
that and my income as you can see has
absolutely astronomical partly because
this Eurofighter is just such an amazing
moneymaker it makes a very steady well a
thousand five hundred euros I'd say
dollars what are we using again we're
using dollars here and these two
coasters are probably making a decent
amount of money as well yeah you can see
that they've only recently opened but
they're already making decent money
especially if you compare it to the fact
that they are barely running for
capacity so far and many
the seats are still empty so I think
theoretically these two could make a
whole lot more even yeah max revenue is
more than three thousand dollars per
month for these two coasters separately
alone so that's quite a lot of money
anyway let's get building again alright
and it is at this point that I finished
this time-lapse and looking at the
amount of time that this video is going
to take a little bit astonished and
afraid because this is going to be
probably my longest video in this series
so far I'm sorry if this thing just
keeps going I am just documenting
everything that I'm doing in this
scenario so it might get boring at some
parts but you can always feel free to
skip ahead to the final section where I
show of the park anyway I'm here to
explain what I'm doing and why and all
of that so I'm starting off here with a
spinning coaster and I realized that I
only use the girl our spinning cars so
far in the spinning course that I've
built and the game also has max spinning
coaster cars for the same track which is
really cool and I just keep forgetting
that some coasters and park tags have
options for different kinds of terrains
so I'm gonna try to remember that and
actually make use of it more often in
the future but here I thought it would
be interesting because these kinds of
spinning coasters have well very
different layouts from girl our spinning
coasters or any spinning coaster anyway
that only uses separate cars because
these have trains which means that you
don't need to put in as many block brake
sections and you can go for much larger
sweeping elements so that's also what
i'm doing here i'm starting this layout
off with one of those horseshoe elements
which are really fun this general layout
is really just based on performance in
toverland which is the only mac spinning
coaster that i've personally been on but
i think it's quite a good indication of
what they are like in general so after
that first elements it's just a bunch of
helixes some s bends to get the car
spinning and some hills in general so
it's just a very simple layout I just
tried to
make it fits into this quite narrow
space as much as I could and also to
make it a bit of an out and back narrow
layouts because that's really the only
thing that I had space for over here and
finally of course a long break run so
that at least I can run two trains on
this thing because if I don't it's going
to be a bit inefficient not that I'm too
concerned about that because if you look
at the amount of money that I have in
the bottom left corner you can see that
I'm already awake
making way too much and this scenario is
probably not going to be very difficult
at this point anymore I'm just trying to
build things in a way that looks nice
but as far as the monetary aspect and
the simulation of the scenario goes I'm
pretty much to happen with this with
this park I really just need to make
sure that I got six coasters and then
we're all set so for this coaster I'm
keeping the scenery a little bit less
over-the-top than the two dueling
coasters because those things are really
meant to be the main attractions for the
park really the flagship right there and
even though we need for this area so
everything around it will be a little
bit more subdued this one in particular
just has a pretty standard looking
station I just decided to add a front
which is more of a Western saloon style
building but it's really only a facade
because the rest of the building is much
more generic and then I've got a very
generic cover over the break run as well
just with some little flourishes here
and there but there's really not too
much to it I decided to add one of these
large round covers for the cue line of
the teacups to make this look a little
bit more steampunky which I think works
well enough even though the design is
clearly a ripoff from one of the covers
that I've built earlier in this scenario
the one for the enterprise and with that
all said I wanted to add a cover to the
teacups themselves because just a
completely uncovered teacups ride like
Sybilla a little bit strange and because
I couldn't come up with any really
interesting shape to put on here I
thought it might be interesting to do
artwork with the roof pieces take the
diagonal pieces and give them some
slightly different colors and mix them
up a little bit to get a sort of Czech
symbolic style roof to this ride okay
maybe maybe it's not that artsy it's
really simple but it's just a bunch of
very random ish elements of colors it's
it's kind of the same idea as a Jackson
Pollock painting alright if you
transcribe that to park effects and
decide to make it a million times more
simple and and just to keep the the
steampunk ish aesthetic a little bit
alive I added a big Tower to it which
doesn't serve any any real purpose but
it has a cool big chimney attached to it
so that's a little bit industrial ish
looking and finally I'm adding a toilet
building here because the nearest toilet
is quite far away from this section of
the park and I decided that I might as
well put a first aid room in there as
well now I'm not too sure how necessary
these first eight rooms are but I think
you know they're one of these things
that you can use to prevent people from
vomiting because they can go in there if
they're sick I believe and then get
healed before they drop all their stuff
on the path which is I guess sort of an
advantage to have but I don't think
they're the most necessary building so
it's typically something that I only
place when I'm running out of different
purposes to give buildings and speaking
of buildings without a purpose I also
decided to add this big tank with
storage for whatever it is that would be
stored in here to add a bit of
industrial vibe to this area and I said
I wouldn't add pipes to anything but I
figured that for this I should at least
add some pipes because realistically
they should be there but because I don't
have the actual steam pipe pieces in
this scenario I already unlocked all of
the scenery that you can unlock in the
scenario and steam pipes are not in
there so can't do much about that but
because we don't have those I decided to
just use the basic shapes for this which
honestly they work
well four pipes you can't use the actual
sphere elements to build the the corners
of the pipes but with those half spheres
you can build some decent transitions
and corners between pipes and the pipes
themselves are just well simple cylinder
pieces so there's a lot of stuff that
you can actually do with those very
basic shapes now moving on from that I
decided to work a little bit more on the
main street's
I know this isn't too much of an actual
Main Street but it's definitely the Main
Street of this park so this is where I
want to build all of the western-style
wooden buildings with those fancy
facades and these overlapping roofs
going over the front of the path so I'm
just adding some slightly varying
designs alongside here but there's
really not too much that's really worth
noting about these buildings I just
wanted to place these mostly to set the
scene and make this whole park feel very
western what I do think is interesting
though is that this is the second time
that I'm doing this kind of theme in
this playthrough of the campaign and the
first time was in park which I kind of
forgot the name of right now but anyway
I've done it before and I kind of went
back to check and see what looked
different about the second attempt and
overall I feel like the colors are a lot
more subdued in this park there's some
more detail to the buildings a lot more
different elements and the buildings are
quite a bit different as well and the
older Park it was much more of a
traditional kind of Main Street set up
with all of the buildings really
attached and really just the facades
being different and in this park the
buildings are more often detached more
details just more different in general
which is always kind of interesting how
there's a change maybe even in the way
that I'm playing the game as we're going
through this campaign because truth be
told it's already been half a year and
I'm only about what 17 episodes in so
I'm not moving too fast with this I know
and also it's been such a long time
you can probably even see my style
slightly changed throughout this as new
pieces or well at least I get used to
new pieces in the game or you know in
general I just change up the way that I
use colors or whatever I do feel like
there are some slight differences in the
style that I'm building things I should
also say I'm sorry about the low and the
slow rate that these videos are coming
out but also these videos take an
enormous amount of time for each five
minutes of time-lapse there's about an
hour of in-game footage and then I need
to record all of the commentary and
things fit it all together edit it
together so there's quite a lot of work
that goes into these things which is why
I can't bring out these episodes as
often as I might want to that set this
episode is a lot longer than I was
hoping it to be and then I'm hoping most
episodes to be and I know I keep saying
that a lot of these episodes are much
longer than I want them to be but
honestly if they're all going to be this
long it's just going to take way too
long to finish the game so I'm gonna try
to put some pep in my step and at least
make some of the other scenarios more
small in scale so I don't necessarily
have to sacrifice on the detailing or
scenery but at least you know add less
things in each Park but then for this
one there's not too much that I can do
about it because the entire goal of this
scenario is to build six coasters or
well to build five coasters because you
already start out with one with an
excitement rating of at least 50 so
that's already a lot of effort that goes
into building different coasters and
giving them awesome scenery etc so yeah
not so much that I can do about it
in this scenario but there will be some
scenarios in the future which will be
much shorter than this hopefully
somewhere in the 2030 minutes maybe a
little bit more range should be more
doable than a video of an hour with many
hours of gameplay in it anyway and
decided to finish up the Main Street
with a few buildings on this side which
are connected but really they're just
different variations of a similar theme
anyway it's time to
into something that's actually exciting
to talk about which is me building this
vnm wing coaster with the launch which
is going to be the sixth coaster in the
scenario and hopefully the one that'll
make me finally finish the scenario
there were a lot of options for me to
choose from at this point because I
can't research researching coasters
throughout its building the other ones
so at this point my coaster tab was
looking very full and very complete I
could even choose to you build a
monorail coaster which is the one that
you unlock in this scenario by getting
700 guests before you get the six
coaches in your park but in the end I
opted to go for a bnm winged coaster
with the launch because that's something
that I don't think I've tried before
these things also really fun to build
and I think it's just the thing that
fits best into the very limited space
that I still have between the the
dueling hyper coasters and the coaster
that was already there I could have
chosen to actually expand the park make
it bigger and put this coaster somewhere
else but I just really wanted to fill up
this empty space and just have the
scenario where every single part of the
map at least the map that is unlocked is
completely built up by coasters which I
figured would look really cool and yeah
this thing just fits right in by virtue
of being a launched coaster so you don't
need to deal with all of that lift hill
stuff which makes it a little bit more
compact and it's also a good excuse to
go kind of out and back because the
real-life coaster that this coaster is
based on which is in holiday world
I think it's Thunderhawk but I'm not
entirely sure if that's actually the
name Thunderbird something like that
something about a bird and some natural
elements anyway the one that this is
based on is also kind of out in back and
even though it's not very compact I feel
like you could build a very similar
layouts in a very small amount of space
so the overall design that I'm going for
here is just a launch straight out of
the station or well at least not
straight out of the station at least a
block break before it's so that I can
actually run two trains on this thing
but also that I launched into a giant
Immelman
than a bunch of elements that kind of
twist in and out of each other before we
go all the way to the back of the park
and this is where stuff actually gets
very difficult so far it was kind of a
smooth ride in terms of building this
because I had a lot of space to work
with but at the back here I need to find
a way to make this thing return to the
station in a way that doesn't interfere
too much with the two hyper coasters
because I didn't want this coaster to go
all over the hyper coasters but also
there's there's paths on the other side
of the valley so there's really barely
any space to work with here plus I
wanted to fit in a long break run so
that I can probably actually slow down
this coaster before it enters the
station and have a realistic final block
break section where I could stall the
second train so yeah this was kind of
difficult to get right at the end I
decided to go with this thing where I'm
building this this curve that just kind
of snakes left's and rights over the
middle section which keeps the middle
section free to build anything in there
and it makes sure that we have some cool
interaction going between the track and
the station so in the end this is the
overall layout that I went with I think
the only downside to doing it like this
is that the layout itself is not that
interesting the second half the layout
is kind of you know just finishing up
the the last remaining energy of the
ride because there are no more twists or
inversions at the end of the layouts
here which is a bit of a bummer but I
think this layout just looks way better
than anything else I had tried so I'm
keeping it like this now as for building
the station it's always a little bit
more of a challenge to build a station
for a win coaster because these things
are really big so you need a large
section of land with no supports so that
means quite a large station so I decided
to go for once again kind of a very
typical station building but then just
add some decorations around it that make
it stand out a little bit more so we've
got that standard roof in the middle and
then some flat sections on the side and
I'm adding a spire here because I love
spires and because it breaks up the
blocky look of the station otherwise a
little bit makes it look a bit more
interesting
and while aspire is always a really fun
experiment also because it just gives
you time to look at all the different
pieces in the game how you can place
them and how you can put them together
to make a unique looking structure which
with spires you can pretty much stick
anything together and see if it works
which usually results in some
interesting combinations of objects so
in this case for instance I decided to
add a very large flat section just
underneath the the spire itself where
there would be kind of a bell tower
section and then on the sides of that
for the decorations I used some of the
steam elements just because the actual
roof borders snap to the grid so you can
only place these on a four grid tile so
that's always a little bit annoying to
work with but the steam pillars the
horizontal and vertical ones are
completely off the grid so you can place
them in whatever way you wants so those
things are a lot more flexible and
they're usually quite useful for things
like this and then the top of the spire
is actually kind of simple just a bunch
of simple wall pieces and a big spire
roof piece and that's about it I decided
to add some foliage around the ride but
it's really just about the same kind of
foliage that's already in the rest of
the park as well just trying to fit this
in a little bit and then I guess the
final ride actually of the park is going
to be this wipeout here which is not
that special I know but I just wanted to
have one more flat ride for a decent
balance so I figured the wipeout would
probably work best it was the only thing
that comfortably fit into the space
without removing the supports for the
coasters so that's what I ended up going
for here a lot of the layouts of this
park and even some of the layouts of the
coasters are very consciously built in a
way to try and avoid removing coaster
supports because one of the things that
I still struggle with in projects
sometimes it's the fact that coaster
supports are removed by paths and things
like that
but it's quite difficult because coaster
supports are often in the middle of grid
pieces so they are on to grid pieces at
the same time which means that if you
build anything on either of those pieces
you might be deleting the entire support
all at once so really a lot of this park
is carefully laid out to try and avoid
removing coaster supports which is also
why I see the paths snaking in some
strange ways every now and then
it's the reason for some of the coaster
elements being the way they are and even
for some of the buildings being in the
places that they are anyway one thing
which I also think is interesting for
this ride is the catwalks that I made
for it I don't think I've really tried
catwalks for winged riders like this but
I think it works out quite alright so we
just have one half roof piece sitting
all the way at the end of one of the
tiles and then three grid tiles away
from that another half roof piece so
these catwalks are very wide but the
coaster cars actually fit just in
between them and the great thing about
these catwalks is that they are
completely on grid so you can at least
put some borders and fences like that on
this side which make them look quite a
bit nicer than if you need to make ant
walks out of pieces that don't snap to
the grid which there are very few of and
I decided to add finally another
building to round up the Main Street
here the station of the wing coaster is
pretty much the end of the Main Street
proper there won't be any typical
western-style
town buildings anymore after that
section although there is some more
scenery we do have the station for the
hyper coaster that was already in the
park and the wipeouts but yeah it's
pretty much the end of the Western town
there
oh and I totally forgot I actually lied
about the wipe I being the last find at
the park this Top Spin was the last
round in the park because I looked back
at this space and realized that there
was quite a lot of empty space in the
middle of the Eurofighter and I was
already planning to put some kind of
right in here
I just couldn't fit any of the rights
that I already had in here because at
the time when I kept checking this space
I only had giant flat rides like the
turbine and the topple tower and none of
them fits well into this space but at
last I got a top spin which fits quite
neatly so I decided to build that in
here it's not the greatest top spin
because it doesn't really show off what
it's doing usually you do want to have
some kind of stage right in front of it
where people not riding the top spin can
at least what people go around on it so
I'm kind of missing that here but there
wasn't too much that I could do with
this space anyway because it's a very
narrow plot of land between two coasters
or well between two sections of coaster
track so this was just about all that I
could do with it and finally I built
this seating area here where you can
just sit down underneath a roof and I
don't know eat or something there's a
bunch of stalls in the area but I didn't
really have places where I can just rest
sit down and eat something so I decided
to add that underneath that roof and the
very last thing in this episode is
building a roof for the wipeouts which
is always a bit annoying because these
things are really tall because when they
start spinning and going up it's really
difficult to fit a roof inside of it or
above it I just reached the goals as you
can see by all of the confetti and yeah
that is pretty much it I know it's kind
of rambling at the end here but I was
just kind of doing things all over the
park to finish it up but at the end of
the day this is absolutely a huge park
so let me show you around and see what
it looks like
all right now I want to do this quick
because this video is already getting
long enough but here's a final look into
the new coasters in the park and just an
overview of the park in general let's
first take a look at the spinning
coaster here so yeah there's not too
much to say about this layout to be
honest it's just really simple I'm just
trying to emulate what these things are
like in real life although I do have to
say it's really difficult to get these
to spin in park texts like you really
need some quick curves and transitions
to actually get these to spin very well
so yeah it doesn't spin that well but
also who actually especially on that
last helix that's actually quite a
decent spin and I know at the end here
it spins quite a bit going into the
brake run as well but yeah maybe not the
best layout from an on-ride perspective
but I think it looks quite decent and it
fits into the park quite well and then
we've got the Main Street over here with
all of these different buildings not too
many of these actually have a use as far
as I remember yeah we have a food court
over here
which is pretty much as the depot plus
two stalls but that works all right
and it's Hoyle it over here but that's
really just about it the rest of these
are all kind of just decoration and here
to create the idea of having an actual
food court now I'm gonna follow the
winged rider here and as you might see I
make the block breaks in such a way that
the waiting time in the station allows
the Train to wait before the launch
which I think in the case of a launch
coaster is actually something that you
want to do just to keep that suspense
just before the launch and I think it's
a decent layer actually I'm really happy
with this it's overall quite smooth and
it's often really difficult to fit these
layouts in rights because winged riders
have such an enormous hitbox because the
Train is all the way on the side so you
always need to have three open grid
spaces on both sides and if you want to
do any inversions you have to be very
careful about any track that's around
it's just because the cars will flip and
rotates and their hit boxes are just
enormous but yeah I really like this
layout and I know I have a tendency to
only show layouts from one perspective
but I think
this one as well as many of the other
ones in the park kind of work well from
many different perspectives this one I
actually really like from this
perspective the way that it looks with
these different curling inversions is
really cool although like I kind of said
it's not the best layout to ride and you
can probably kind of tell that I made
this to look good from an isometric
perspective I would have probably liked
to make it a bit longer on this side if
I had any space for that and fit in an
inline twist somewhere as most wing
riders will have at the end of their
layouts could have even been over here
but yeah given the space that we have in
this scenario I wasn't really able to
fit that in but overall I'm pretty happy
with it
and I'm also really happy with a lot of
the other coasters in the park though I
have to say my favourites are definitely
these two hyper coasters I'm super happy
with how these turned out and I guess I
should probably point out some of the
excitement ratings on these coasters as
well I thought it was interesting about
this one that the purple has a higher
excitement rating than green I believe
yeah green only has 80 and purple is 86
which i think is largely due to the fact
that purple just has more airtime
especially with these major airtime
Hills at the end here so yeah I thought
that was interesting we also have a an
excitement rating of just 53 on the
spinning coaster I actually had to put
quite a bit of scenery around this to
even make this go above 50 so at least
scenery makes quite a difference this
was originally a 44 48 yeah I think
excitement rating but then on adding all
of the scenery around it made it 53 so
if you just can't make the excitement
rating go on a scenario fret not you
might still be able to get there with
scenery as well the wind coaster is
quite decent with 81 and the Eurofighter
I actually don't know ninety-two
cheese's that might honestly be the
highest excitement rating of any coaster
that I've worked on in any of the
scenario Maps huh that's pretty cool
although maybe the underground section
has something to do with that I'm not
entirely sure I wouldn't see what about
this layout is
so good but sure I'll take it so yeah
that's it we've got the entrance area
over here with the quirky sort of
steampunk looking building here large
main streets with all these very western
town style buildings and finally a
wipeout and the orbiter that was already
here and if you look at the park from a
distance
it's just a giant spaghetti of different
rollercoasters I tried to give each one
of them a slightly different color but I
also wanted everything to have kind of
steampunk ish colors so we've got a dark
industrial kind of red color here purple
and green but in the kinds of shades
that I think would work very well with
the theme
this one's just brown which is a bit
boring but I couldn't really find any
other color that looks good with this
Trek type this one's orange inspired by
holiday worlds Thunderbird but a
slightly different shade of orange
that's a bit more gritty and I also
recolored the first coaster that we had
to some kind of dark blue ish it's hard
to tell exactly what the color is like
and it's very close to black but it's
not entirely like anyway that's just all
of the coasters I'd like to thank you
guys for watching this episode and I
actually can't wait to see what the next
Park is going to be because once again I
actually have no clue and I'm actually
not sure what the trophy on this is
going to be either okay so it's just the
little mining equipment that's on the
side of the hill oh that's really cool
the way that it fits into the hill is
really nice and after that we have a
path going through the mine and oh it
comes out over there I was not expecting
at two parks but I'll take it
so this is probably kaiserburg yep there
we go and then we still have Hickory
Hill and this looks like psycho rock
garden no okay okay I did I didn't spoil
anything I legitimately didn't know what
was coming up but looks like we've got
pagoda Valley coming up first yeah but
you guys might probably already know
that there is a scenario out there
called Sakura Gardens I guess it makes
sense that these guys are
next to each other in any case yeah I
said it
in any case I have no idea what I'm
going to do in the next episode but I'd
like to thank you guys for watching this
one and I hope to see you in the next
one bye guys